yo guys this is the thing
so last week on the pod I had my gal pal
Cheryl Patrice and we had so much fun
and we dish so much that I was like you
know who I'm having back this week sure
ro but true hey girl you're not in you
know what's great about you you're so
open so many times girls come on here
and they're like afraid to like share
what's really going on really yeah oh no
I do I think I've sometimes to open but
I'm like [ __ ] it like you live once it
is what it is being real - you know what
that money is like lately I swear okay
we're both you and I were both
attractive girls I would say you're
again you're turning and I look I'm not
at all your Instagram I'm like well can
I get a body like that little mile away
I know but can I get on with me my girl
is this trainer she's going down I'm
obsessed with her I'll take you that
it's called Barboza it's on Sunset
anyone know where you should check it
out but thank you but I also like just
know my angles you know from doing
Instagram if you know how to I look so
much better in photos by the way than I
do in real life to just everyone watch
yes editing goes a little cutting
editing yeah Photoshop Adelson yeah I
won't even send a guy a naked photo
without photoshopping it by the way
that's why I don't [ __ ] with snapchat
I'm like I can't put a shelf on there
yeah do you send nudies yeah sometimes
but I've pulled way back on it I don't
really ever I will once I'm at an axe
threaten to like put my pictures out and
it happened like years ago so like I
literally have stopped sending nudies as
effective like maybe three four years
back Wow but so illegal by the way
called revenge porn again my lawyer
about it oh yeah I know like so I don't
know I was actually technically illegal
but like yeah he liked the right and he
was like I'm gonna put these out and
send them on the blogs whenever and at
that point I wasn't like anyone like I
wasn't really doing I was like okay but
I was so scared and so now like I'm now
that I'm out more and I do social media
and you know building a career I'm even
more nervous so yeah I mean those
pictures may pop up eventually and
prepared as long as you're good anymore
as long as they're good though that's my
thing I'm like as long as they're I'm
happy with them I just I get more
nervous about someone hacking my phone
and posting the outtakes of it I don't
want the photos of me that I didn't send
that I was like my ass looks bad not one
to lead them there's why your pimple on
my labia whatever you know no I don't
even take those like I literally I don't
even have any in my phone like I went
where I was soaked because here's what
happened my sister would also take my
phone and go through it and so then she
would like to run in to tell my parents
if I took like sexy photos so also I
stopped taking pictures because she knew
my passcode and I just stopped I don't I
don't even have like seductive pictures
any picture of me that's sexy I will put
on Instagram because I'm like if I put
it out in the public then I'll still
send those photos to guys like to make
them fun why so funny it's like you
can't resent a guy a photo that you post
on Instagram page that I do it all the
time I'm like oh you don't follow me
here you go oh that's hilarious you
don't think they look at your Instagram
even if they don't fight oh no I don't
really care but it would be the same
thing this is a question that I have
what reason does a guy have if a guy's
into you and he doesn't follow you on
Instagram I don't know about you I
assume that means there's another girl
always I mean some guys like it depends
on what they do like I know they're on
Instagram then maybe but some guys like
I don't even want to follow them first
of all I may not even like their page I
mean like this shit's [ __ ] boring
like I'm not trying to add to my
follower account
oh that's a good point so sometimes I
just don't even want to follow them so
it's just easier if I like don't even
tell them and also step ends where I
meet like sometimes I meet men in like
more of a corporate setting because I
didn't have a job job and I do do like a
very kind of corporate look and so
depends where I meet them I don't
necessarily want them because I also do
like thirst traps on Instagram and I
don't want them to think like oh he's
plotting around yeah yes I think that -
oh my god I was out with that guy the
other day and he was like asking me like
did you research me did you google me
and I go no I don't Google guys no
matter who you are because if someone
Google's me they're gonna think I'm like
just straight-up trying to [ __ ] for sure
yeah not the case
exactly and like oh my hands are not
very strategic with what I put out like
I
no when I'm thirsty I'm like I'm
specifically like telling my girlfriend
like listen like take hit let me hit
this angle and take this photo let me
throw a filter on it because I like
stuff like I know what I'm doing we all
know like when I post a sexy photo
I'm very strategic it's like only one in
every picture you don't want to do too
many but you gotta do one on occasion I
mean that's it it's just what it is it's
an exactly but I don't think guys
necessarily know that so they may see it
and think like oh she's a ho or she's
this or that and if you don't know me
then like I guess you're obviously
welcome to judge people going to judge
regardless so I'd prefer like I don't
even like to mention it like yeah but I
will sometimes ask them but I won't tell
them what mine is because I want to go
and look at their page and like get
their info but I won't ever follow them
or tell them I would and but like I
don't actually want them to follow me
because I'm also like unless you're out
there like commenting and liking photos
like look I mean if you're going to
engage on my page but I don't
necessarily hate when a guy starts out
liking all your photos and engaging them
once you start hooking up they suddenly
stop like I don't want to seem too into
you I'm like mother brother like to me
it's supporting you if a guy I'm dating
likes my stuff I notice and I'm like oh
that's nice he supports what I do that's
all that is you don't have to be like
commenting but liking is nice yeah like
let me let me know that you saw I like
it I think it's cute but what I was
going to say about you being so honest
is that I've noticed a trend lately
where I mean the reason I said we're
both attractive girls I don't think I'm
like this crazy hot girl but you lately
lately I've been getting guys taking me
out that are like a level above what I
think I can get does that make sense
like but you are hot like to be keep it
all the way gee I mean what an amazing
body you have it really pretty safe we
have an awesome personality and you're
funny like I'm sorry I think that's a
really strong combination and this is
not just me saying this like I look I
mean I'm on your anything and I'm like
kind of yeah so I this [ __ ] looks
amazing in a bathing suit so well thank
you and you have stuff going for you
yeah some but but what I was going to
say that I've noticed a trend with these
guys that I think are like quote
not out of my league but because I don't
think anyone's out of anyone's league
but just like you know I date I
typically date guys that don't really
have their [ __ ] together and lately I've
been dating your a lot of guys with
their [ __ ] together but what they all
say to me that they love there's three
in my head right now I'm thinking on
that are like you're so different
because you're so honest you're just
real you say what's real you don't play
games you don't [ __ ] around and I'm
starting to realize like how much men
appreciate when you're just like real
because so many girls are trying to play
games yeah I hate games especially in LA
like I feel like city of games yeah and
like with social media and everything
now like no one wants to like put
themselves out there and be real
everyone wants to pretend that they
don't care and so games are like big and
it's annoying cause I feel like you hit
a point where you're just like I don't
want time to decipher all this stuff
like that I don't know what does mean I
don't want to spend an hour figuring out
what sex back or what you're mean you're
dead like just call me exactly and if
you don't do that I'm just going to cut
it off because I'm just at the point
where I'm like I have too much to do
then like trying to decipher where you
fit into my life and what this means is
not part of my to do it 100% so okay
there's a couple things I want to talk
about today because it's girl-on-girl
which I love and so does it so to the
people at home so I'm in a situation
I've never really been in before which
many guys are in by the way all the time
okay which is first of all I'm dating
multiple people like I'm I'm dating too
regularly but I'm still also going on
dates with new guys and so but there's
so I have a little rotation which I by
the way never have ever I never do I try
but as soon as I like one I usually
start ignoring the other ones by mistake
prank you can't help it when your girl
yeah right you're like I feel guilty I'm
going to cut it off exactly but here's
the thing
so right now I'm dating these two guys
that I really like both I really like
both and I'm not [ __ ] either one
which is great right I'm making as you
can't wait you don't need to feel guilty
about that like in your one I feel like
there's so much shaming on women when
women explore options and I think that's
one as a woman why not keep your options
open like why not explore you're not
having sex with them you're getting to
know both of them I don't feel that you
should have to obligate yourself to
either person right and men do it all
the time and so I feel like as a woman
like I want to figure out like which one
do you like which one of you is going to
survive like hey we get my final rose
exactly no I travel it out let's see
like let's see who really wants to
invest in me and invest in our future
this is the thing though I've never had
this situation because first of all
there couldn't be more different these
two guys okay
one guy without giving I don't want to
give away too much but like let's just
say one guy extreme alpha male athlete
that's all I really wanted the exact new
garage very hot
okay I'm from the first time I met him I
was like he's so hot I'm so attracted to
him and I had a crush on him and he's
funny as [ __ ] he's not a comic but he's
so funny would you know girls yeah they
love that [ __ ] right
and the big thing total gentleman I mean
like I've known her rare I've never
dated a guy like the difference a this
guy we went out the other night every
time I had to pee
we were out from like I don't know 7:30
until 1:00 a.m. or something right every
time I had to pee walked in the bathroom
I've never had a guy wore a bathroom in
my life
he was like you gotta go I'll go to I'll
lock you he would walk me then he wait
for me outside the bathroom he's almost
like protective custody I felt little
security with me the whole night
hilarious yeah I mean I just know
and you know it's like he wouldn't let
me I mean not only I mean of course guys
don't let you pay for stuff sometimes
but like he would let me open a door she
wouldn't let me I mean just like a small
stuff should never touch your door I
know like I notice stuff like that like
I think that's really really cute when
guys do that like walk on the outside of
the sidewalk like stuff like that I
think it's I do too but it's just like
becoming so rare I was talking to my
girlfriend today and she goes you know
it's funny case he's just doing what men
are like
supposed to do but you're down away
because so few guys do it anymore
right like back in 1950 this was the
norm right right so that guy he's so hot
everything good at a crush on him for
the longest time the only thing is he
lives a little far so it's kind of like
but that's kind of a good thing too
because he's not close enough where I
can like want to see him very much and
what's weird is normally with guys as
soon as I start to like them I start to
kind of obsess over it you do that yeah
yeah it is it's like I would not because
when I love I love heart so when I fall
I'm just like oh I'm the same know if
when I go like I go and so I always at
the conference I think that's one of the
reasons why I'm so picky and like
specific now because it's like when I do
invest I invest really like a thousand
percent girls are such thinkers to like
you get in your head reap yeah and you
can't stop thinking about like what do I
just mean what is it why is he do in I
think that brings to the point of why I
think it's a good thing that you date
and give yourself options like until you
get to that point where both people have
decided well let's be exclusive and
let's just build upon the two of us I
think it is important to date so that
you have that experience of kind of
saying okay well like if you're going to
drop the ball there are men out there
because I think sometimes women we get
so down on ourselves and believe that
there aren't but there's not going to be
another man that's going to treat us
this well so let's just suffer this guy
go with that one cuz right out of like
exactly like yeah a little bit of
attention so I guess like I'll speak to
him and like drew cos that's true but
what's weird with this guy is
much as I like was into him for so long
and he is super hot but there is
something like I'm not worried about I
don't know like I don't think about is
he with another girl when I'm not with
him I really don't care yet it doesn't
act good it's it I think this is healthy
what I am so used to being so obsessed
over like these player type guides that
I am always like thinking about it but
with this guy I even told him I go you
know what's weird is like with you I
just genuinely like you and since we
were friends for a while I feel like if
it happens it happens if it works out it
does but if it doesn't I just like you
so I I care about maintaining this
friendship and like it's the weirdest
easiest there hasn't been a moment in my
head where I'm like I wonder if he's
into me or I wonder if he's playing a
game he texts me like once a day and
goes like today text me he's like he's
like thinking about those lips that's it
so simple but you're like as a girl like
oh yeah you know what I mean that's it
yeah I mean I think girls who just are
so used to getting caught up and so used
to like getting like sucked in and so
it's like it's nice when you just have
peace of mind and you're like you know
what like I go to sleep and I'm not
wondering what you're doing and I find
it so bad it is because we're not used I
feel like but I think it's a maturity
thing and I think it's probably it's
within you it probably has nothing to do
with him it's just like your confidence
and knowing like you know what like I'm
going to enjoy this I respect myself
I respect the situation at the same time
I'm still exploring my options and I'm
mature enough to do that in a
responsible way and give yourself that
peace of mind where you're like I'm not
going to be stressing about what this
person is doing like but also I don't
need to because it's like isn't it so
hot when I do this my girlfriend's often
that for me 99% of how I feel about a
guy has to do with what happens when
we're not together because when you're
in a room with someone it's easy to be
good charm them act right right ler if
you have chemistry right that's the
easiest part oh absolutely
but it's when you're not around each
other the guy that wins is the guy that
acts right when you're not around and I
don't
it has nothing to do with other girls it
just has to do with like is he thinking
of you to do check-up with you did you
care what's going on with you does he
you know what I mean like that yeah so
like oh did you get there safely like or
like hey I'm just thinking about it you
want to say hi like that makes such a
difference dude I do a test on guys when
I go out with them you know when you go
out with guys how they always say like
text me like I know you got had ha yeah
I never do
oh and you wait to see if they contact
you because they really give up because
I think they just say it cuz they're
supposed to but do they really care for
your address actually my dad told me
that exact same thing and he was like
wait to see don't text him wait to see
the guy hits you always ask if you are
at home yeah because you make it home
okay or great I always wait for them to
text me that's so important okay then so
what happens if they don't text you that
do you cut them off or well kind of like
no I just know in my mind they weren't
without worried about it and I go to so
it doesn't mean I won't go out with them
again or something but the next time
when they go text me if you get home
safe I'll say it
I'll go why last time I didn't you
didn't seem too worried yeah like yeah
else what happened me obviously nothing
but you didn't really mean it right
matter date or what if you just don't
text them that you get home safe and
then the next day when they text you you
go by the way I got mugged last oh my
god I was I'm gonna you should for real
for real tennis by the way my favorite
driver Milan believe me I was writing
text you I didn't have in a ditch in
Tijuana like trying to cross the border
give me a couple hours like I had later
oh my god okay so that's guy number one
okay because I just know the reason the
reason I want to talk about this is
because I this is interesting and it
says something about women because I
know you're going to relate so guy
number two he's also successful very
they're both successful guys okay so
they both have their [ __ ] together they
both have jobs neither one is like a
loser guy number two I think it's super
cute I'm very attracted to him right if
I put them side by side in a room what I
say he's hotter
maybe not but like I have more chemistry
go ahead it's crazy so like have you
ever been out with someone that you have
the impulse to try to kiss them like
multiple times like on the first day but
you don't but you're just like that
attracted today nice in there
so I went out with this guy maybe five
times before we kissed they weren't all
dates a couple times were like group
hangs we kind of talked a little bit on
social media before we first met but I
haven't known him as a friend so we
don't have the same whatever right this
guy's an entertainer not an athlete and
so we have great conversation we're in
the same field
you know so like we can kind of relate
more on that which is good and bad yeah
cuz we talk a lot about show business
where when I'm out with the other guy we
dabble in it maybe but not a lot and but
this guy's got a very like little kid
like playful I mean there couldn't have
more different backgrounds one guy one
guy grew up in the hood one guy is like
you know probably grew up more like me
like a nice neighborhood whatever so but
the thing is what this guy is for
whatever reason I feel when I'm with
this guy just like kind of crazy about
him
like I'm so attracted to him we kissed
finally after like the the third date
this is the third date one-on-one okay
where he kissed me and it was until the
end and I was fighting the urge to kiss
him the entire date a laugh but I didn't
and then at the end we had this kiss
that was like you know what a guy kisses
you and immediately you go oh we're
gonna have yeah hearted sex oh yeah you
know you just you go you're just like
okay yeah like you're like we know it's
gonna happen yeah and he's not a guy
that's normally my type but I just I can
already tell a guy I had to do
everything my willpower to get the [ __ ]
out of there and not go home and gotta
go you know yeah yeah for real and I
even finding my creeping into my head
sometimes
at home alone like you know getting off
like I'm thinking about him a little bit
but here's the thing so that guy we have
this amazing kiss right and then he text
me the next couple days and then uh like
he text me the next two days but didn't
try to make plans again and then he text
and then the next day I hit him up and I
was like maybe he's like a little he
seems to me like maybe a little insecure
like every time we Punk out I he's hit
me up first I've initiated the hangout
oh god I mean yeah like you've actually
been the one that finalized yeah like
what's up tonight you want to get a
drink what I yeah
so this time I'm waiting for him to do
it I'm like I'm not doing it he needs to
be the man he needs me the one to ask so
I'm waiting and waiting
we're texting for four days oh my god
and he doesn't ask but he's saying [ __ ]
like you know I feel like what you and I
have is really rare it's really like
he's saying all the right [ __ ] but then
he's not and I feel like with guys it's
actions not were absolutely right so I'm
whoa yeah 100% yeah so I'm starting to
be like it's this guy is it just
wordplay is he as into me as I think
because I can tell him into him but you
know I did tell him I said I'm not going
to sleep with you for a while just I
want you to know now it's going to take
a while because I really dig you I want
to see where it goes first because also
we work in the same business now range
and he's like yeah of course take your
time there's no rush I'm super into you
I just like talking to you but then
after I said that he kind of backed off
a little right then that makes me kind
of think that that's his like that's
really his MO he really like he's being
this charming person initially but he
really is just like trying to sleep with
you because to me if that was the case
where he was cool with it
why back off why be like distancing
verse being like I want to hang out with
you like if that happens like it'll
happen in due time but yeah dope check
like I want to spend time with you first
this other guy that is really investing
in the time in like two so to back off
after you've told him like hey I want to
see where this thing goes
and then he backs I think that's his
tell well so this is the thing
so I totally agree so I kind of called
him out which I never do by the way like
I try to be like the chick that's like
chill because I'm trying to learn to be
chill time ratio at all
so I finally sent him a tags okay and my
text was basically I was like I was like
oh I try to be cute and flirty but get
to the point right so I said hey you
what's up and then he wrote back hey hey
what's up with you and I said well you
tell me normally when a guy kisses me
like that
he tries what is it he picks a time to
see me again
pretty soon why are you waiting winky
face like I called him right out right
right and then he said um oh is that how
it works
winky face which I was like oh gross
wrong respond response right I should
have been oh yeah of course I've been
busy how's Friday night or whatever
right that was the invitation thank you
schedule a specific time thank you
so then he said um hang on him at the
gym let me hit you back oh yeah which is
I'm okay lately our bead view I'm okay
with that if you hit me back right then
two hours goes by nothing oh he's
playing games he wants to sleep with you
that's through nine games he wanna sleep
no no I'm glad that you said that
because here's the thing so then I text
him back I waited two hours and then I
just said you know what don't worry
about it
I hate games I'm not interested in this
I say we'd be friends I pretty much
called him out right now here's where I
think it's fascinating that you said
that he texts me back like immediately
of course like three paragraphs
explaining everything that's been
happening with him this week why he's
been so busy I mean it all was logical
made sense I understood but then he was
like I don't understand what you mean by
playing games I've only been busy I love
hanging out with you I'm so attracted to
you I do want to keep spending time with
you he's like if I was playing games I'd
be trying to sleep with you I'm in no
rush so I think it's so funny because in
the guy's mind
he's like if I'm not trying to bang you
it's not a game and in the girl's mind
all I thought is it's a game the minute
the minute you stop trying to see me but
you keep flirting granny that feels like
you're just keeping a door open but
you're not going to that that's the
truth like that's how it is to me like
first of all I've done sales a lot and
in sales there's a thing called a take
away and so on a take away you basically
remove like it when a person isn't
showing interest you remove what it is
you're trying to sell and say you know
what you know I don't think this is
right for you I'm gonna just go ahead
and let ya cancel this out and then that
shows where their interest is now so I
think what what you did was you did a
take away and I don't but I don't know
if it's genuine you like I don't know
what he's saying I didn't know limit him
to eventually sleep with you or if it
really is because I feel like when it
comes to the old dizzy thing people make
time for the things they want to make
time for I've been incredibly busy
before and I will still make time for a
person if I want to make time for that
person owner goes they're not in that
like top five list like I'm not going to
make time for you but if you are like I
add a 1 a.m. when I'm getting home I
will
FaceTime or see you or whatever the case
may be so I will squeeze you in into the
little pockets of time that I have yeah
that's right thing I'm going to call BS
on him and I'm going to encourage you to
go with the other guys with other guys
go with the other guy and it's so funny
because the thing with this dude is that
the conversation is so grey and he
always he does like when he does text me
he's always like curious what are you up
to how was your day how was that
audition how was that like it he
genuinely asked the right [ __ ] but I'm
starting to just realize it guys it's
all action it is I think what men like
one thing I've learned when a man wants
to be with a woman a man will move
mountains to be with that woman and when
you find that person that genuinely is
like no like I want to be with you and I
want you to realize that I am the man
that wants to be with you and I'm
willing to out fight all the others yeah
I'll do what he has to do and so I just
kind of feel like I've been with men
like that I've had an ex that was like
that and he was like within a month he
was like listen like I'm feeling you
like I don't want to play
I want to be with you so let's like I
want you in my world oh ha when a guy
just says what they want exactly ok
let's cut the BS like now we got to go
through the workings of being in a
relationship but it made me realize like
when you're dealing with a man that
knows what he wants like a man will do
what he has to do to claim you as his
woman if he's not doing that then he is
playing games and if you guys agree and
it's like you just got to recognize it
for what it is and move on that's how I
feel and it's funny too because for him
to be like well if I was if I was
playing games I'd be trying really hard
to sleep with you do you see because he
did say when I told him I'm waiting he
was like take your time and no wrong you
as an option well and also it's like
just because it's a long game doesn't
mean it's a game right I've got guys
that I know are just waiting for me to
break down and hook up with them one day
I think you got athletes that have
played the game for two years and
finally one night maybe we get drunk
together and we hook up right and that
could very well be it he's like hey I'm
going to keep it as an optional I'll
flirt with you occasionally but I'm not
going to actually put the time in
because what he's doing is hitting you
up to keep the door open but he's not
actually saying let's meet at this day
at this time and go do this and I'm
gonna invest my time my my money into
seeing you verse like well let me hit
you up occasionally via text message in
like yeah keep this going so that when
that time comes I'm here there's
something I want to say to the guys that
are listening right now because I don't
know if guys realize this and this is
huge because with this guy for instance
I understand busy because I'm in show
business
he ain't sure I get it sometimes you
have week it's literally back-to-back
meetings auditions shows you're crazy
you have to prepare for the next day you
don't have time to see someone he is
texting that's nice here's the thing the
guys I think don't get if you make plans
with a girl so she just has something to
look forward to that is so huge so huge
guys don't get that like guys hate to
make plans and a lot of times I'll have
guys say to me like well I don't wanna
make plans because then if something
comes up and I have to cancel you might
get upset I would rather a million times
over a guy be like hey are you free
Friday night let's get dinner
then if he books a gig or something
comes up any grant he cancels I totally
get it that's legitimate yeah but it
gives you as the girl the whole week
you're like all excited cuz I'm going to
see them Friday and by the way guys just
so you know if a girl is like kind of on
your ads are blowing you up or like
harassing you're nagging or whatever a
lot of times once you give her a day
she'll go away I will go away right
you're like oh cool I'm set up there for
this one yeah I got the date I'll be at
the gym I'll be d-dog right I'll be
making sure not to eat that day in case
we [ __ ] whatever the thing is you know
so it's like I think guys are so
hesitant to make plans they want to keep
their options open and [ __ ] like just
know if you're if a girl is like getting
irritated with you there's a very good
chance that if you just say to her are
you free Saturday night at 9:00 she'll
go yeah
great can't wait and then we'd be the
[ __ ] alone right it's so real now it's
true it's like I just think it was women
like just we want to show it be shown
interest we want like the thing is with
women we're very I think we were
complicated that simple at the same time
we just want to feel like we're adored
we just want to feel hahaha that's all
like I feel like you're feeling us yeah
like a little dungeon affection some
councilman exactly just a little bit so
if you want to play this game like and I
think when you're like young and you're
delighted that 2122 age like you put up
with so much BS as a woman and like you
like or get strung along and then as you
mature you realize like no I have worth
like I'm gonna go it in like is that
important you don't danger I think it's
like you have to realize like listen and
you're not going to do it another man
well so I'm only the door for him so
funny is I really do think that this guy
and by the way this other guy lives very
close to me which is why it's even more
of like a kind of a slap in the face
like you live 10 minutes away but you
don't even be like let's grab a coffee
or whatever right so my thing is if you
know if you are if you're in the
neighborhood especially if you're close
by like the chick knows you've gotta you
gotta step up
he's close and is making Susie I excuses
and I just think that like you
me say that I'm busy it's just a cop-out
like I have been busy and I will still
make on your visit you made time exactly
there weren't the very least there's way
to show like being thoughtful like hey
like I only have a five five minutes a
few hours or whatever but like I want to
see her I want to speak to you like just
something so I'm thinking of you I may
not be able to give you in person time
or may not be able to talk to you on the
phone for an hour but I just want you to
know that I'm thinking about you and
once I have that time like and they will
plan they'll be like listen I'm free on
this time so if someone's not planning
like that means that I bring you as
option number two three four exactly yes
I totally agree because I bet you if you
were like hey I wanna [ __ ] you tonight
he make the time I thought dude if I
tell him and I would I already tried
anyway by the way I almost as an
experiment was gonna send him because he
had a birthday and like if I'm dating a
guy I always send them a naked photo on
their birthday always but I make it
funny like I'll put like cupcakes over
the boobs or at like a hospital like you
I almost as a test was going to send him
a photo like that but then I was like I
don't want to set the wrong precedent
because I'm not going to bang him but I
was just like I'll bet if I did
[ __ ] would be like oh exactly
right yeah and that's how and that's
exactly what it is like you'll go I'm so
busy and I don't have I go to explain
that he sent you a whole paragraph of
excuses but had you sent that picture he
would have freed up real quick I mean
recognize and free at 8:09 p.m. tonight
hundred percent so I just I just want to
say to the guys out there that if you're
into her ask her for the next date no
matter what when it doesn't matter what
it could be a week out it could be five
days out plans might change but just
trust me when I tell you that girls
the problem is were brought up to
believe the guy is supposed to ask you
for the next day at the end of that like
there's just these things in that we're
taught that if you don't do it we start
to think you're playing games and games
are not always sex related sometimes
game I assume by the way if I got any
time a guy's attention is somewhere else
I assume it's another chick always yeah
if you're not coming
to get me guys aren't going without sex
yeah so if you're not trying to get it
from me you're trying to get it
somewhere else that's what I assumed and
I think all those women like ladies like
you gotta start like I think women
should have options like I feel we're
chasing and believing that we can't have
a rotation that we can't beat multiple
people I even been to ok them and shut
yeah and I think it's ok to sleep with
them as long as nobody thinks that
you're exclusive and you're being safe I
mean you gotta test the waters look my
friend today she goes to me she goes I
think you should [ __ ] them both and see
who wins
haha and I'm like well that's a viable
option that I might the problem is I
know I'd have better sex the guy who's
bad for me because that's how it works
on it but you know what for once I'm
going to try to actually date the guy
that's giving me no drama yeah and the
other guy by the way this is funny
because I'm pretty sure I know it sounds
like he's running game but he is a very
busy successful he I believe that he's
busy but what's funny
that he doesn't know is like he could be
winning so easily but I'm very close to
just cutting him off and letting the
other guy win because he's not stepping
it up well let me ask you is this guy
the second guy that lives close to you
is he on social media
yes did he post a little bit yeah ok so
if you have time to be on Instagram or
Twitter or Facebook you have time to
contact me he does text me he just
doesn't but by the way it's me my other
pet peeve with this [ __ ] and and
this another note if you're going to
text me a conversation that's serious or
that goes on for more than like 5 or 6
days just call yeah please people like
people are afraid to call like I feel
like we're in this culture of like text
message is totally and people don't know
how to like I will tell people call me
like I don't want to [ __ ] text all
the time I'm old-school like I value a
phone call because I said with a phone
call I get to know you I hear your voice
I hear the today like we're speaking I
don't want to talk to a computer scream
there's one thing if we have to or
you're busy and like you're in a meeting
or something you can't speak but like
anyone that actually legitimately
friends with like we get on the phone is
if you're a guy and you can only text me
like this is going to go nowhere and
after a while if you're only if it's new
and you're seeing each other once a week
or every two weeks that
texting in between starts to feel so
distant you start to feel like you're
texting with a robot it's someone you
don't know like the kids are but that
guy was so hot but to be honest with you
now after all this texting I don't even
think about the kids anymore I just
think about all this [ __ ] texting
right so it's like if you just called
you could say if you called me a couple
days ago hey I just want to say hi I've
been so busy you can't wait to see you
again whenever that would a different
conversation yeah texting you this long
paragraph if he had called and picked up
the phone and said you know what like
this is what's been going on with me I
just wanted to get on the phone with you
because I don't want you think I'm
avoiding you like I just have been
legitimately like crazy schedule that is
a very different experience than sending
a text message yeah because in a text
message in a girl's mind and this is
probably stupid they go oh well I'm
sorry I've been in bed with guys that
have been texting while we're I mean you
can text from anywhere and be lying but
if you call me I hear your voice I you
know calling I wish my headphones stand
I also think calling is it's more
intimate because we've lost it as a
society like the value in calling is I
remember yeah we were like in high
school and talking on the phone for
hours like that was the thing to do and
it was exciting and it was fun and I
feel like as a culture we've lost that
and so like now I value hearing
someone's voice and actually having that
time also the boys feed yeah the voices
part of it attracts you to them to like
like this guy I actually like I think
his voice is so like the other day
instead of a text he sent me a voice
note and I was like oh it's really cute
to hear his voice guys don't get like
that's all part of the attraction and
absolutely same for guys
I noticed the guys I date sometimes
there was a guy that we would be having
these massive fights and then the second
I would get him on the phone he'd soften
right away and I could tell it because
he heard my voice nearly any car it's a
dome and it's a real like a text message
all you're doing is speaking to an
electronic device you're not actually
talking to that person yeah you're on
the phone it's like you hear that
person's voice you understand what
they're feeling and you read a lot just
from hearing in the way they say that
they speak to you
and I think like how do you just picked
up the phone and called you and said
that even if I weren't available and he
had left it in a voice message I think
you would have received it so
differently than him send
as a text or even when I texted him and
said I feel like you're running game
that is the moment to pick up the phone
not send me back 75 text messages which
is nice he explained it and I get it and
like boy bye but I mean call be a man
how ball right man that's why the Alpha
guy is going to win because he's a
[ __ ] man first there's such a
difference and when you're dealing with
a man versa boy well it's such a
different experience and you're just
like that's when you feel like this is
how a woman is supposed to be treated
this is how I am supposed to feel
because you're supposed to feel safe and
protected and a man will make you feel
safe and protected a boy will make you
feel insecure and make you question
stuff and make you have to decipher some
yeah and this text message [ __ ] like
I think you just have to be able to read
stuff for how it is because I'm sure
you've text guys when you're gaming them
and you're like I'm busy that's like
horse well you're like he's an option
but I'm not super into him but I might
date him again so I'll keep him on that
we do the same [ __ ] Ashley yeah that's
all I had to look at I'm like there's so
many times when IBS men and just been
like and dizzy and getting a little
whatever like I've done the same thing
so when that happened to me I'm just
like your running game the same way I've
run games so I'm just now at the blame
it's like I'm smart enough to realize
what it is and if that's the case like
I'm not going to waste my time like it
yeah but you will end on that like do
not call this real fast I think it's so
funny the second I accused him of
running game he was like but to run game
you if you're running game you're trying
to put the ball in the net not hang out
with the net and I'm like yeah like
first of all but game can be run long
term you may just be like hey I'm just
holding out to see if something works
out eventually like I'm willing to to
just play my cards and if maybe it turns
out like I just think you have to go off
of action and one person is showing you
through directions like hey I want to
build with you I want to grow with you
and another person is showing you
through the actions like hey I'm not
making time for you and this isn't a
priority for right you got to just read
it for what the other guy came from 60
miles away to see me girl if you come
from 60 miles away that means you still
I know 60 miles in a la la I know like
during Tropical illusory our uber
surcharges girl that that's awesome you
have some really premium dick right
exactly like I'm here doing our surge or
right turn against you know I know I'm
glad we had this talk that was debating
going down to see him tomorrow I think
I'm just gonna go I think he's winning
for sure
so so give him that same like slow grow
yeah but I think that I'll show you
through his actions he's like I'm not
allowing distance to affect us seeing
each other you don't even have to drive
you don't want to spend your gas or put
the miles never narked and provide and
he can do it if he's an athlete like
he's fine
take care of it you don't let him take
care of it and don't feel guilty about
that and then still grow slow and allow
see where it goes and you can still
explore a date and whatnot but actions
speak so much louder than words and it's
so cliche to say this but it really is
true like I think as a woman you doesn't
know like once like something someone is
showing you real genuine interest or
someone is biessing 100% this is deep
this will see my dad like I want it
since we have real I want to get real
and [ __ ] like that like that like this
was not it's not always funny but I
think that this is insightful I think
it's real I think every girl's been
there and I hope you guys are learning I
hope that guys are just learning or like
a little bit about what women are don't
looking and gentlemen if you're
listening out there and you have a girl
that you're actually interested in like
puddin work like make her know that
that's what you want to build on like
telling like don't play game games are
wack like if you want to be wacko play
your games but if you actually like are
interested and a woman make it know I've
been listening to this dating coach I'm
going to give him props his name is
Matthew Hussey he's amazing he has a
huge following you should check him out
and I've been like researching some of
his stuff for like stuff to talk about
about on here actually but one of the
things that he says all the time that I
think is brilliant is he says pay
attention to the level of investment
guys are putting it if it's a text hey
that's a low investment text if the text
is like I've been thinking about you how
was your audition that's specific that
the high
like look at the air ducts all of you
your bigger investment exactly yeah like
I want to hear about Harvey says hey are
you free for coffee like I want to hear
about your like there's levels or even
hey I live right up the street why don't
you pop by I mean by the way I know
girls if a guy invites you over you
assume it's sex but once I tell the guy
I'm not going to hook up with you for a
while then that's a free pass for you to
invite me to your house because I
already told you so what I find
situation yeah
anyway this is bad but I need to do a
commercial not just have a commercial
for we have sponsors on this show and
this is a great one I'm really excited
about I really mean that like it sounds
like total [ __ ] because it's a paid
ad but I've been using this product and
I actually really like it so I want you
guys to check out bio clarity that's it
and guys you know men can use it also or
you can buy it for your wife or
girlfriend I mean if what it is is an
amazing skincare line it's really great
stuff that they'll send to you in the
mail bio clarity I love it
because there's no chemicals in it I get
I can get dry skin so easily and
especially the older I get the more I
want to be like dewy and I just I feel
like the bio clarity it does not many
harsh chemicals in it a lot of normal
face cleansers and acne treatment have
bio clarity is naturally calming it's
got cleansing extracts got green tea
chamomile it's almost like a at home
facial for your skin it cools your skin
I am obsessed with it I told you last
time I'll get you some it's amazing
no benzoyl peroxide which is what cause
causes the redness and the dryness and
irritation this combines the power of
prescription-grade salicylic acid with
flora lux which is restorative and it's
made from chlorophyll which is you know
what makes plants green so very natural
guys I want you to check it out for sure
it'll definitely reduce your blemishes
it'll make you more glowy which I love
and you know I think that everybody
wants to feel confident in their skin
especially nowadays talking about all
the social media it's huge so I want
y'all to make sure you try it out the
way to do it is go to bio clarity calm
and if you listen to this podcast you
get your first month for only nine
five plus free shipping so you save
twenty bucks all you have to do is enter
my promo code date date date
one time two state bio clarity comm
enter the promo code date make sure you
guys check it out it's great stuff and
I'm very grateful to them for sponsoring
the show and I'm grateful to you guys
who support the show through patreon
check out patreon comback /k q funny if
you would like to donate and support and
of course my fabulous guest I'm so
grateful you did two episodes give the
killed both you help me thank you for
having me the new self on dude you
really honestly should come back any
time you I would love to amazing these
anytime you behind me and for the record
I'm slightly tipsy for you've officially
gotten me you're welcome
players and Sherrill you helped me
figure out my situation guy one is away
in the lead I'm not even going to talk
I'm not going to deal with guide to
anymore I think I'm done with him I'm
getting the getting the feeling he's low
level [ __ ] boy status like I'm not sure
is yeah and he's like successful [ __ ]
boy I mean I don't think he has the I
think he would be a [ __ ] boy if he had a
little more game but I think he's right
policies I don't know at [ __ ] boys I'm
not sure okay
I think guy one but still pick your time
because I want you to like I want you at
like wife status what I want like a
looking ring on your finger and invite
me to the wedding so I can be like
listen I'm the one that taught herself
anyone else we hung it on by the way
just FYI guy one definitely has hot
friends I can introduce you to so maybe
should come with me tomorrow like like
for real girl actually like my dad lives
in Orange County so I'm not even joking
like one who lives in Orange County can
we hang out let's go down yeah let's do
it all of them send us a lift premiere
date and we can live premiere from LA to
Orange County to Mexico we're here
everybody listen follow at Cheryl
Patrice on Instagram gonna post a photo
so you can find her and she's absolutely
hilarious and what's your facebook again
facebook is facebook.com/paes yeah yeah
yeah and she's I'm Twitter Cheryl
Patrice gorgeous so if you look and you
get up
[ __ ] boys not doing that no [ __ ] away
I'm gonna get you a bubble you know I
have [ __ ] boy patrol gear now fo I'm
going to get you a [ __ ] boy patrol like
tank top or crop top so I will rock that
yeah how do I pose that control Annette
[ __ ] yeah shut of the [ __ ] down I guess
I love it guys make sure you subscribe
to the podcast if you liked it please
leave a nice review that's always lovely
and we will see you next time on date
bells bye